more and more at more cars more on our roads
than last year and there'll be more next year
and the year after that more and more cars will be
built and more cars will be bought and every one
of them will be entitled to room on our roads
and highways the thing is will there always
be room for one more car well there isn't even
enough room now today many of our highways are
already obsolete what would happen on them during
a national emergency the entire population under
panic conditions trying to escape depth on the
highways is one of America's greatest problems
major factors in this mounting loss of life for
the roads and highways themselves they are not
engineered for safety or for the number of
cars now using them President Eisenhower's
militant call for a grand plan to provide a
modern controlled-access highway system for
safe efficient transcontinental travel led to
the passage of the federal aid Highway Act of
1956 he dramatically underscored the fact that our
interstate road network is inadequate locally and
obsolete nationally the president has led the way
to positive action public road engineers have long
been making plans to meet the growing emergency
of highway obsolescence they have worked with
scientific detachment to create the interstate
highway system that we need today and must have
in the future in charge of this great program is
federal highway administrator Bertram Dee Ptolemy
the program involves the construction of 41,000
miles of Expressway connecting every segment of
the United States in addition to that it includes
the construction of many hundreds of thousands
of miles of state highways of city arterial
routes and of secondary roads we usually call
those farm-to-market highway there's no question
but what completion of this wonderful highway
construction program will affect everyone from the
national defense point of view it's indispensable
the beneficial effects of this program are certain
to be felt in every community in the entire United
States the greater Hilldale luncheon club meets
every Wednesday and of course everybody is there
mr. Harper who works at the bank mr. Gunderson
one of the community's most successful farmers
mr. Huggins is a pretty important farmer to
Emma Glock is the chairman of the hill Dale
historical and civic Beautification Committee
and it's largely due to her that Hill Dale is
one of the prettiest and cleanest little towns
in the state sally owns a neat little coffee
shop and bill who has a service station and
garage eats there and so does ben who has a
motel closeby today mayor Willits is presiding
the other evening my seven year old daughter
Gracie asked me what I thought was going to be
a very difficult question so I began with the
birds and the bees what she frowned and shook
her head and said I know all that old stuff
daddy what I want to know is where do all the
automobiles come from mr. no no I guess speaker
who is an engineer with United States Bureau
of Public Roads can answer Gracie's question
as he talks to us about the new national system
of interstate and defense highways mr. Norton
Thank You Mara will it ladies and gentlemen I
think the most important question is not where
the automobiles come from but how they're
going to get where they're trying to go in
a typical state our roads and highways resemble
an accidental natural growth the main stems the
branches between in crossing this state from A to
B about 200 stops will have to be made some four
stoplights many to avoid other vehicles such a
system or rather lack of system wastes time waste
fuels and as a big factor in our appalling
accident rate what is needed is one overall
master plan for our roads and highways in this
plan there will be no intersection access will
be controlled it will really unite all of our
united states it'll be possible to drive from
the Atlantic to the Pacific Ocean and from
Canada to Mexico on safe multi lane divided
highways without a single stoplight or stop sign
you will travel swiftly easily and safely because
safety for the traveling public is engineered
right into the plan this system of interstate
and defense highways is for the traffic of the
future at the rate traffic is increasing it is
absolutely necessary for our towns and cities will
be literally strangled in a few short years would
you turn the lights on please it will benefit us
tremendously economically it's a vital importance
to national and civil defense and it'll make life
easier and more enjoyable for all of us thank you
and so the pleasant friendly life of Hilldale
moves on each week pretty much like the last
just as it does in all the pleasant friendly towns
that are the backbone and sinews of America mr.
Harper was born in this fine old house built by
his father like all of us he's glad to return
to it at the end of a busy tiring day grandma is
proud of the Harper home and takes special pride
in the old trees especially those planted by her
husband who set one out for each of their children
hi darlin I think Oh Oh same as usual downtown
today Helen you remember two or three weeks ago
we had a highway official a speaker at the lunch
Club yes yes you told me about it freeway linking
the whole country one of those freeways is coming
here Joe Hill Bay Oh wonderful why will it go they
don't say almost everyone in Hilldale is concerned
about the proposed freeway nobody knows anything
beyond the fact that it will certainly bypass the
town they are afraid that without that traffic
Hilldale will become a ghost town mr. Snavely is
ill Dale specialist in dark suspicions he is sure
this freeway thing is just another boondoggle to
waste the taxpayers money the biggest local news
is of course the coming of a freeway to Hill Dale
as we understand it the highway people have three
alternate routes but their locations have not
yet been disclosed there will be a meeting of
the high school at 10 a.m. Saturday at which
time an engineer State Highway Department will
good morning ladies and gentlemen my name
is gray I'm the deputy chief engineer of
the state highway department this is mr. Anderson
planning engineer together we hope to be able to
answer the questions that many of you want to ask
about the new freeway as part of the overall plan
for a chain of expressways crossing the country
from east to west and north to south one of the
freeways serving our state will pass near Hilldale
my name is Simmons I raise poultry I don't see why
this freeway can't go straight across the state
instead of dipping down to what the interstate
system is designed to interconnect and serve
the major cities in the military and industrial
areas of the United States the location of
the cities which are the points of origin
and destination in this part of the system
make it necessary to build the freeway near
Hilldale the national plan cannot be engineered
unless the whole picture is taken into account
my name is Williams now they tell me that you can
only get on these freeways at certain places now
why can't you get on wherever you'll want to the
reason we must limit access to the freeways is
that we wouldn't have a freeway very long if we
didn't an old-fashioned highway without limited
access can be entered at any point along the
route by individual and of course stoplights
must be installed at intersections without planned
access business establishments soon spring up at
the corners and extend along the highway parked
cars take the right-hand lane we no longer have
a highway it becomes the congested Main Street
of a small town with limited access there is
a frontage road which serves the business areas
which cannot build up directly on the freeway and
choke it to death as the main street of Hilldale
is choked right now my name is Bill Jordan I have
a service station on the highway just outside
of town Ben here owns an auto Court Sally is
the coffee shop in the same place Oh we'd like to
know what the freeways gonna do to us it looks to
us like it'll drain a lot of people it might be
customers off the highway where we are it looks
like the money that the travelers now bring into
town will stay on the new freeway and we'll never
even get a chance at it our experience indicates
that that isn't true for one thing money that
might be spent in Hilldale now goes on through
town suppose the highway traveler does want to
buy something the chances are that they'll be out
of town before they can find a place to stop then
to most of the traffic on the main street of
Hilldale is not there because it wants to be
most of the travelers are simply trying to fight
their way out of town once Hilldale is served by
the freeway the travelers who have no intention
of stopping in town will go straight on thus
relieving the town's to congestion but travelers
on the freeway I like everyone else the time comes
when they need something and the freeway will be
properly signed to let them know where they can
find it after all every one of them will still
need the ass and oil all of them will eat three
times a day and sleep in a motel or hotel at
night such a freeway traveler will turn into
town to find what he wants he'll spend money in
Hilldale because that's what he came there to
do careful studies of existing freeways such as
the New York Thruway the Houston expressway and
expressways in California New Jersey and other
places indicate that in general business in
an area served by a freeway shows an overall
increase and property values show remarkable
Rises it's because travelers can get into town
move around find a place to park and buy what
they want also the freeways have much greater
traffic capacity and they're pleasant to drive
on so they're just naturally more people for
Hilldale to draw kind of makes sense all right
my name is Miller how are all these people going
to know where to turn off to get the things they
need your state highway department will give you
the information on the towns and cities ahead
and the services they offer clearly and boldly
like this even on the darkest nights we'll see
these information signs as brightly as by day
reflectorized signs leap into life thousands
of feet ahead when caught by your lights and look
exactly the same at night as by day in conjunction
with proper signing highway lighting will show
the way clearly and safely on and off the system
in addition all hazardous locations will be
clearly illuminated on our present highways
one third of the traffic is night traffic yet it
produces two-thirds of the fatal accidents good
letting will correct this situation I'm Gunther
Singh I have got farmland that will be cut no
matter where you go and I am NOT going to stand
for that and how do I get on there sure no phangan
road drive 10 to 15 miles it'll be closer to 4
miles today you only have to travel about 1 mile
to get on the present highway but it's a pretty
slow road as part of this accelerated program
our farm-to-market roads will be developed as
feeder roads to the interstate system and once
on the freeway you will cut the time it takes
you to reach your market by more than half your
produce will certainly arrive at the market in a
much shorter time it will be fresher and should
bring a better price you will sell produce that
might otherwise be lost and you will be able to
select the markets with the highest prices yeah
yeah maybe this year a freeway be pretty good
thing but not to cut my land a fair price will
be paid for any land taken and damages will be
paid for any property severed from the rest
and this a possibility oftentimes of a trade
CEO Lee our land is side-by-side
they cut your north end and my
Roger they Pierce then I trade you
my in and for your end yeah they
got to get up pretty early in the
morning to fool all the Gunderson
mr. gray I am Emma God the chairman of Hill Dale's
beautification and historical committee I've been
studying these maps and each proposed route will
destroy some natural beauty or some historical
treasure of this community after all don't these
things have some cultural and social value man
does not live by bread alone mr. grey I agree I
also believe that a cleanly designed and perfectly
functional highway has a beauty of its own also
the expert landscaping of a freeway often becomes
a distinct community asset whenever possible
in our bigger cities rights away are located
in blighted or slum areas which helps to clean
them up and we must never forget the safety of
the freeways we must do what we can to cut down
the appalling accident rate today on our way we
must protect our children we're beginning to drive
and the freeway accident rate is less than half
the national average sometimes we do have to give
up a cherished thing in the interests of progress
and the greatest good to the greatest number what
you've been saying makes sense to me I think this
new highway will be a good thing for Hill Dale
can you tell us at this time exactly where it
will go three routes have been surveyed but the
final decision will not be made until we study
the record of this hearing if you pick route
able to go smack right where my store is put
on B no sir route B would ruin me all those
young trees my greenhouses put it on route
C wait a minute would still take my drive-in
theater that's a mighty big investment put it
on Road a well put on B or C A or B but not beat
what are you fellows talking about Nazi believe
me Nazi you've gotta put it on gentlemen please
the freeway must go someplace why why should you
outsiders come in here and tell us we're gonna
have a freeway the way you plan it why can't we
have our own engineer to check these things let
him tell us if we need a freeway and if so where
it should go one of the purposes of this meeting
is to ensure that equal consideration is given
to local needs because an interstate highway
is coming through the community the state will
gladly cooperate with your local planning
engineer all right what happens to all this
money as taxpayers dig up well a lot of it goes
right back to you property owners the rest of
it goes to the men who do the job engineers
both in government and in consulting firms
which design many of our bridges and other major
structures those who manufacture the machinery
the equipment distributors to perform a vital
service by furnishing and servicing the machinery
then there are the suppliers of material such as
aggregate cement asphalt guitar corrugated steel
pipe aluminum for lighting fixtures bridge rails
and sign and steel from massive bridges guardrail
lighting standards wire mesh and other reinforcing
and last but certainly not least is the army of
workmen employed by the highway contractors
how do we know what getting our money's worth
and who gets these contracts all the jobs are
advertised publicly and qualified contractors
are invited to bid in accordance with our
American system of pre competitive enterprise
anyone else please my daughter-in-law ever
well she's married to John and they live over
in West forks the freeways already been built
over there they think it's just wonderful but
I've been wondering about these great big
dangerous machines all the clatter and dust
and confusion how long are we going to have
to put up with such goings on well those big
machines they're not really dangerous because
they're handled by experienced men trains are
operates with safety both for the workmen and
for the public under the skilled eyes of safety
engineers of course there's bound to be some
inconvenience in a project of this size but
the work around Hilldale won't take nearly as
long as you might think everything moves fast
because the engineers and workmen are sure of
themselves today we move mountains out of the way
instead of going around coordination is
modern and thorough there's no waiting
around our modern designs with
long sight distances and gentle
sweeping curves are made possible
by our great earthmoving machines
on the biggest jobs we're actually
able to move up to 30 tons of Earth
in a single carrier at 25 miles an hour
and modern paving machines unwind the
rhythms of road before our eyes at an
unbelievable rate gauche if there are
no further questions the hearing
is closed thank you all for coming
well I got to see it it's a lucky thing for
them I don't own any property where they're
gonna put that thing you know Stavely I think
it's kind of lucky for all of us that you don't
every dad registered letter yo turn the TV set
off turn it off what is it John it's from the
highway commissioner highway commissioner
we have found it necessary in locating the
new interstate and national defense highway in
the Hilldale area to acquire your property for
right-of-way and would like to arrange at your
convenience a meeting with our appraisers and
negotiators to establish a fair value and
arrange the terms of the purchase you mean
the freeway is going to come through our place
that's what the letter says they have no right
to do this this is the upper plate it always has
been and it always will be I'm not going to have
these highways people come in here and tear on
our good trees I turn my house into rubble No
these are my trees and when those bulldozers
come they'll find me sitting right here in
this chair and if they're going to take the
house in the trees now they'll take me too
Joe run out until Vanuatu come back in the house
the bulldozers won't be here
for two or three months yes yes
I've been thinking a lot about what we do
it and I believe there's only one answer
there are always some people like mr. Snavely
who don't want progress they're just against
everything that's new and different whether it's
good or bad but they never win now we don't want
to give up our home any more than anyone else
wants to give up theirs but anybody with any
sense it all knows that this system of roads will
be a good thing for his country and for all of
us it's something we really need as a matter of
fact we've got to have it if we're going to move
ahead in this country the way we always have
so it comes down to this we all want the roads
but we want them on somebody else's place not
ours we all want the benefits in the progress
and the safety and the convenience we want them
without having to disturb our own set up well if
we want all these things the highway has to
go someplace now the routes are selected by
experts who have nothing against us they don't
even know us they just designed the road to go
where it'll do the most good for everybody and
for the overall plan well it happens that this
road goes through our place and I think we'd be
pretty small-minded if we tried to fight it I'm
sure we'll be given a good price for our place
and we can build a new house and as far as I'm
concerned I just don't think that any family or
business or individual has any right to hold up
anything that'll be good for his whole community
and for his country too well third before too long
the freeway was completed and it all happened
pretty much the way mr. gray had said it would
the useless dangerous traffic jam was gone
and Hilldale owned its own streets again the
people who had been inconvenienced for a short
time we're all in fine shape business was good
property values were up even grandma had to
admit there's about as much satisfaction in
planting a new tree as there is in admiring
an old one maybe a little more and above all
Hilldale itself had become a part of progress
had taken its rightful place with all the
other active forward-looking communities
that have always made our country great